on va tous tenir à bord
1250 dollars par personne voilà comment
on va manger quoi une
relaxation
c'est le mélange qui provoque en bouche
cette explosion de saveur arrête de dire
nous ferons tout notre possible pour que
cette soirée vous soit agréable
[Musique]
bienvenue à hauteur
nous formons une famille
on récolte pour fermente on fusionne il
fusion on fusionne ce n'est pas qu'un
chef c'est un compteur d'histoire le but
du jeu c'est de mettre en lien les
indices pour deviner le thème du repas
ça bien sûr on saura qu'à la fin
qui êtes-vous je suis Margot qu'est-ce
que ça peut vous faire j'ai besoin de
savoir êtes-vous avec nous ou avec eux
ce menu les images sont tout en lien
avec nous la liste des invités comment
ils
ça sent pas bon le déroulé de la soirée
[Musique]
il l'a fait pour de vrai
ok 45 secondes à compter de maintenant
tout ceci fait partie du menu
laissez-moi passer
ça fait partie du menu
[Musique]
joyeux anniversaire
tu leur a dit que c'était mon
anniversaire je trouvais que c'était une
bonne idée il y a trois heures